can you dig it
yes you can at dig this las vegas the
world's first heavy equipment playground
but john now they're getting serious by
offering a heavy equipment training
school and that's oh my goodness mary
jane delieza is right now look out she's
got she's got the best on you go mary
jane
yeah nate john you know i got the vest
on i got the hard hat on so
i guess you could say i'm gonna get
ready to dig this we are out here in
front of the excavator i'm inside you
can already see that i'm getting ready
to kind of demo this so i'm going to
pass the microphone over to edmund who
is the ceo of dig this he'll explain
what i'm doing and this is kind of a
good preview to give a glimpse of what
students can look forward to when they
take this class so here ed i'm going to
go ahead and give you the microphone
okay mary let's just get out of your way
here
okay
so we're we're just going to have a
little bit of fun of course when you're
at the academy it's about teeth learning
and and working but uh we're just going
to have a little bit of fun here at the
moment so
with your left hand on the left hand
joystick i've got us now going to have
you take it to the left and we're going
to spin around to the left okay
now of course this is one of the easy
tasks the students will be learning out
here
as you can see this is very modern
equipment the students will obviously
learn
the safety checks in the morning first
and then i'll also go over the safety
components before they jump in the
machine make sure everything's working
good and then we're going to
start to learn how to excavate which is
why we call these excavators
they'll learn how to dig holes they'll
do a little bit of grading
they'll also learn how to load dump
trucks
and they'll also learn how to load the
machine on a trailer and sufficiently
tie it down
all right stop there mary well done okay
now with your right hand let's put that
down on the ground so right hand forward
with your right hand joystick yep just
put that on the ground there
all right
okay so uh stop there and you can put
your safety brake on there thank you all
right well done mary good job
okay so we have other equipment
obviously available here for students to
operate we've got our backhoes
we've got our bulldozers we'll be
bringing loaders online soon and then
you know there's a good variation
equipment here
the courses will be one week long
and
they'll be specifically designed around
the heavy equipment of the choice of
their whether it's a bulldozer excavator
uh or loader uh which is coming later
but we'll fully focus on 40 hour
programs each week so they can get
signed off on each piece of equipment
perfect yeah all right thank you so much
i'd be appreciate it reporting live mary
jane valeza live local now
you feel mary jane